from Canada to portion size we want to
find out all the differences between
lace chips in the U.S and in India this
is food Wars
here are all the latest trips you will
find in India that you won't find in the
US and here are the latest ships in the
US you can't find in India oh my good
God yeah
yeah to begin things I'm gonna go with
the one I hate the most Spanish tomato
Tango yeah I've just never really like
this flavor it's just too heavy on the
Tomato side
no oh man that after this is horrible I
have nothing nice to say about this
flavor also just to note our standard
lace chips come in the ridge style we do
also sell the flat style but that's more
of a special variety of lace next it's
West Indies hot and sweet chili formerly
Caribbean hot and sweet chili
that's what I'm talking about
get out of here and now
for the Maharaja of Indian leaves magic
Masala if you haven't heard of this you
must be living under a rock because this
is the little emperor of chips commonly
known as blue leaves
look at this cheap dude
oh my God
it's already so spicy the reason this
chip has become so popular in India is
because they have actually managed to
capture the Masala of India so well and
Masala if you're wondering is like
ground up spices that are added to every
single dish we eat here this is truly
magic I want to know what they're like
Joe got himself something
and the chip bags in India are like much
harder to open
oh man you guys got them locked up tight
is it gonna rip okay yeah
oh yeah
damn you're good
not too spicy great flavor we have so
many flavors I couldn't get them all for
the shoot I mean I'll just start right
here
barbecue this is like the classic chip I
think this is more popular than the
classic to be honest the US has I would
say at least 10 different variations of
barbecue possibly more so I have just
like standard barbecue is pretty bold
move by Leia's salt and vinegar
I love salt and fingers so much I love
it so much
chop chip top chip right here love song
cheddar and sour cream
another favorite oh man
it seems like
lime flavored chips would be weird or
citrusy chips but
so good and these are like really limey
all the super fans watch and know I do
not like pickles
no let's kick it up a notch blaming hot
dill pickle and the flaming hot that
font that implies that's like flaming
hot Cheetos right
um better still not that good ah last in
this group is a chili lemon
yeah
these are coming home with me other
flavors in this category that I couldn't
get the time of filming cheddar jalapeno
and Sweet Southern heat barbecue I was
totally able to buy them online I get a
thing in the mail two days ago saying
the post office is holding them Ransom
and wants five more dollars for postage
for me to pick it up not happening I
will not be intimidated by the United
States Post Office and keep the chips
all right also what I couldn't get at
the time of filming was honey barbecue
Chesapeake Bay crab spice Adobes which
is a different spicy chip which is
actually very good I was bummed that
couldn't get those and the Doritos Cool
Ranch lays unfortunately
let's now talk about two exclusive
flavors that are in both countries but
slightly different we have uh the
sizzling heart lays and the American
style cream and onion it was previously
known as American sour cream and onion
it's great no fudge one of my favorite
flavors it's been there for like over
two decades I feel in India and there's
a reason for that ours is just regular
sour cream and onion I also got America
style sour cream and onion from India
and then one after the other
the flavor on these are much stronger
and even says now with more food this is
more flavor I gotta say I like these
India ones better up next we have
sizzling hot this is the flavor I've
actually never had I'm very excited to
see how it Stacks compared to Magic
Masala which is already pretty spicy
whoa
yo look at this chip it's literally red
oh
nice it's not as much a direct heat as
the magic Masala it is a nice flavor in
the US we have flaming hot Flavor now
let me explain this is flaming hot
kettle chips couldn't get the regular
flaming hot we'll get into kettle chips
later it's like regular spice as a heat
to it without being too specific I think
they use use red chilies right here
it packs a nice punch without being too
overwhelming with the flavor they're
like the perfect amount of heat without
getting too overwhelming so okay so we
don't only have ridge style chips we
also have some flat ones in fact they're
called wafer style which I think is
pretty much your classic style of lace
the first flavor is salt with pepper not
salt and pepper don't you dare say that
it's very nice I should buy this more
often I've never tried this before very
good job okay on to the next wafer style
chip we have sun-dried chili
I love sun dried anything beam that Sun
Ray on to any vegetable I will eat it
this is really good they smashed through
this one
got a prop okay well oh
it's really yum and one of the most
beautiful sights you'll see in India is
people Sun drying their own chilies on
their roofs porches wherever biryanis
curries they all use sun dried chili and
this chips packet really has nailed this
flavor
maybe my favorite kettle cooked we
already saw the Flamin Hot kettle cooked
these are thicker chip they transport a
lot better obviously and has made broken
a potato taste to it potato snaps like
I love cattle chips sea salt Cracked
Pepper
yeah
like
sea salt and vinegar this ain't your
pond Salt this ain't your Lake salt this
certainly is not your Fjord salt
why is salt and vinegar so good
attention everyone my favorite Kettle
chip is about to be eaten by me the
jalapeno kettle chips I'm not going to
talk about Miss Vicki's because this
isn't a Miss Vicky's video and I hate to
say it
these might be better
we've got the jalapeno flavor in there
it's not too spicy so you can really
Chow Down on these moving on
unfortunately to something that I kind
of can't stand are
baked you get them in original and you
get them a barbecue
like eating cardboard lays has something
called the better for you Series so we
have these and then lightly sell the
barbecue lightly salted wavy I mean I
want the salt but like how much
this is what paper tastes like we got
simply sea salt thick cut
and you can also get the simply barbecue
thick cut you have something called
layers which are these guys bite-sized
layers crispy layers tasty layers you
get them in three cheese sour cream and
onion I've never seen this before my
entire life oh the best stinks
oh these are these are really bad these
are terrible well these are real
chemically tasting oh my God these
tastes like they were poisoned I know
for the next range of exclusive chips we
have lays Max
that's Max with two x's why the two x's
that's the like thing it's more better I
have not seen or tasted these before
starting with Macho chili flavor it is
kinda rich but I would say it's more
very
I wouldn't say it's super spicy I kind
of like that this one doesn't leave that
burning sensation in your throat it's
really nice
yeah I I don't know about The Branding
but I really like this flavor next
flavor peppery cheddar
whoa all sorts of stuff happening here
there's like some mint to it oh you know
what this tastes like this tastes like
Malai Tikka like chicken Malai Tikka
dipped
in pudina Chutney this is very uni our
next flavor is
sizzling barbecue oh the reason this is
called lace Max it's because it has Max
crunch Max flavor and Max taste and I
can wholeheartedly say both of these
have delivered
foreign
these work they're great
more fun chip Styles I think we can call
these the India style but we also call
them the wavy style they are wavy hence
the name and you get them an original
reduced fat honey barbecue Ranch you
also get them in salt and pepper lightly
salted fat low fat if I didn't say that
already like the waves are like wider
you guys have like really like condensed
waves Blaze apparently went into answer
the age-old question how can we copy
something popular and make it much much
worse and stacks were invented you guys
know what Pringles are right of course
you do well
hear that we'll put them in a tube they
won't break as easily right
holy
look at us
so what was the point of putting in this
tube I hate this so much but to really
prove my point yo dog look what I got by
the way paper tube excellent idea Dave
Pringle whatever your name is
stacks and now to our final set of
exclusives The Gourmet collection I have
had a lot of gourmet food in my life and
I've very rarely been actually impressed
with the food wantos cheese and paprika
vintage cheese
and paprika
oh if I taste this chip without any of
the fancy packaging I don't think
Gourmet is the first word that would
come to my head Thai Sweet Chili Gourmet
this literally tastes like the West
Indies hot in chili but on a flat chip
so Gourmet is just packaging that's what
we've learned from this experiment with
these two chips
skippable in addition to that we also
have lays poppables poppables come in
sea salt and vinegar see oh Julius
Pringle that was his name not Dave they
also have poppable sea salt and vinegar
poppable sea salt poppable white cheddar
and poppable honey barbecue okay I don't
want to eat all these what's the what's
the cereal that looks like this is it
Chex
if you got these on accident eat them
but I wouldn't I wouldn't reach for
these over regular potato chips
it's coming five sizes it is 30 grams 50
grams 73 grams 104 grams and 174 grams
the big boy the party pack I feel like I
could eat this whole thing on my own to
be honest in the US our lace chips come
in six variety of sizes all the way down
here got the 28 gram bag which comes in
the multi-pack next up 74.4 Gram bag in
the middle here there's also an elusive
78 gram bag look I saw it on target.com
and walmart.com it exists it just wasn't
available anywhere in Southern
California I looked okay one step up we
have what I think is the classic
Grocery Store bag
226 gram aka the eight ounce bag you've
seen it a million times this is the one
right next to that one is the family
size bag which I also couldn't get a
hold of
297.6 gram bag I couldn't find it
because the American family is dead but
what is Alive and Well is of course our
biggest size the party size
368 grams for all you familyless
Partiers lays has you covered that means
that the biggest bag in the US is this
much larger than the biggest bag in
India but wait there's more or less
depending on the packet that you get
because according to Amazon the weights
of these different packets might vary so
they're given a weight range the biggest
weight difference is in our largest pack
of 174 to 190 grams which is a
difference of 16 grams so let's see how
much we get in one package
175 grams one gram extra from what is
advertised which is I'll take it so let
me show you what 16 grams of chips looks
like so you can see what you're
potentially missing out on it doesn't
seem like a lot but I think that's quite
a substantial amount of chips you're
missing out on to be fair they they did
write 174 grams only on the pack in the
U.S our flavor bags weigh less than the
original flavor bag take this barbecue
flavored lace bag it weighs 7.75 ounces
or 7 and 3 4 ounces Yulie can we get in
there you see that thank you compared to
the eight ounce you get with the
original bag okay same price less
product now Harry did research on that
episode so take it away Harry
what no do your own research according
to Harry's research from the last Lay's
episode back in 2014 PepsiCo claimed the
reason that there is a slightly higher
price per ounce for flavor chips is the
added seasoning so then lays can you
explain to me why this lightly salted
bag gives you fewer chips in the
original bag it's more money but less
salt a lays check it out the lightly
salted so less salted than this also
seven and three-fourths while we're
exposing potential lays lies this 28
gram bag in the U.S supposedly contains
15 chips according to Lay's website
let's see how accurate this is and I'm
going to go on all the tips in this 30
gram packet to see how many we have
I mean it doesn't contain one whole chip
one
twelve
thirteen I mean if we're doing it by
chip related piles 6 12 8 moving close
to 18 chips per bag huh all right I'll
concede cool so that's 24 chips I would
say realistically this is like 20 chips
that have been broken into many other
pieces but let's be real they could have
fit a lot more chips into this packet
and laze is notorious for filling it
with air it's actually nitrogen gas
which helps preserve the chips and also
acts as a cushion to stop them from
getting smashed in transit I mean
what would it have been like without the
cushion this whole bag would have been
dust apparently but what is the air to
chip ratio you ask let's find out in a
new segment I like to call the our
chipmedies principle
can I just say this is one of the
weirdest things I've done in my life a
generous 55 mL of chips in this packet
now let's measure how much the packet
itself can hold in volume
oh this smells so bad
900 mL that's
845 mL of chips that we could have had
lays I feel cheated which I think to
make it more accurate let's do four and
then we'll fill this guy up and then
we'll divide by four and that would give
us the average of those does that make
sense dust
all right
oh man all right can I please have the
scientific chip crunching nunchucks
throw them
ah whoa look out chips pow pow pow
2.75 fluid ounces per bag now that's
science you can use
so now we're going to fill this with
water
the whole thing's 20. I'm just about
2.75
17.25 units or whatever cubic fluid
ounces even more interesting ad
information because if India is very
geography the amount of air that's
packed into these packets is different
for different altitudes for example in
cities of higher altitude like lay in
the Himalayas there is the risk of these
packets exploding
due to the low atmospheric pressure and
so when they're sent there they're sent
with no air at all inside of them and so
they run the risk of being crushed in
transport so they have to be taken as
delicately as a crate of eggs
[Music]
but what about price
this is our largest chips packet the 174
grams and on swiggy and Amazon this
sells for about 78 rupees which is about
a dollar right now and that equals
rupees 0.44 per gram about
0.005 dollars and yes I did all of that
math and conversion in my head here in
the us if we break it down starting with
this big bag the 226.8 gram AKA eight
ounce bag it's 3.99 at Target or
316.58 rupees yes it's a bigger bag I
know so breaking it down per gram we
found that in the US the cost is at 260
increase compared to India while we do
enjoy our lace chips we also have a
giant chip culture here in uh India in
fact these are called hot chips and they
sold all across India at stalls called
Hot Chip stores where basically they
have a giant frying pan and they cut the
potato in front of you to these thin
slices and fry it and give it to you
nice hot hot fresh fresh and so for 174
grams which is the same as this you're
paying rupees 45 for a lot fresher chips
so as you can see lasers competing
against a giant chip Market here in
India and doing pretty well I would say
[Music]
now for the burning question are there
any questionable ingredients that are in
your lace chips that you need to watch
out for fret not because Joe and I have
found them out for you as far as the
basic salted version goes you're totally
fine both in India and the US they're
made of potatoes vegetable oil salt
warning warning alert here in India some
of our flavors have an ingredient called
potassium chloride in regular doses this
is completely safe and it's a low sodium
alternative to Salt however it's also
one of the three ingredients used in the
three drug cocktail
for Lethal Injections too much potassium
chloride will cause irregular heartbeats
and boom your heart will stop so if
you've been thinking of doing a lace
mukbang be careful we don't have any of
that in the U.S lace but we do have food
coloring caramel color in our barbecue
and honey barbecue chips certain types
of caramel color can contain a byproduct
called four dash me uppercase i studies
found that it caused cancer in rats and
mice leading campaigns in support of
banning it from foods give me that
dancing rat
all right the FDA was like nah it's fine
humans don't come close to the level of
exposure that caused that rat tumors but
that didn't stop the state of California
adding it to its Proposition 65 list of
chemicals quote known to the state of
California to cause cancer or
reproductive toxicity end quote another
ingredient found in several varieties of
relationships here in India is disodium
glutamate AKA flavor enhancer 69 no not
69.
flavor enhances 627 but basically it's
used alongside MSG to enhance the flavor
of the chips both the Food and Drug
Administration or the FDA in the United
States and the European Food Safety
Authority or the efsa consider disodium
glutamate safe but it's not recommended
for babies children pregnant women and
lactating mothers and also should be
avoided by asthmatics or people
suffering from gout MSC if you're
wondering is the commonly misunderstood
ingredient known as monosodium glutamate
which is added to a lot of Asian Cuisine
and gives it that Umami flavor in 2019
lays sued a bunch of Indian Farmers for
growing a certain variety of potato
fc5 variety saying it has a patent on
that variety this type of potato is
ideal for snack chips as it has a lower
moisture content but strike one of the
little guy Farmer's rights activists
petition the protection of the plant
varieties and Farmers rights Authority
and it agreed PepsiCo Lays cannot claim
a patent over a seed variety it was
revoked immediately and the Indian
potato farmers are now flush with low
moisture potato money let's go
[Music]
so which country has the unhealthiest
chips let's compare the classics first
a 28 gram bag of classic lays in the U.S
contains 160 calories uh 10 grams of
total fat 1.5 grams of saturated fat 15
grams of carbs and 170 milligrams of
sodium okay so our least nutrition is
put 100 grams so I did a little bit of
math to compare it to the US 28 grams
actually during the mat so if the math
is wrong blame you okay so we have 154.8
calories total fat 9.8 grams of which
saturates are 3.7 grams carbs are 14.7
grams and sodium
142.8 milligrams wow that was pretty
close actually we're under the U.S in
every metric except for saturated fats
where we are over 164 percent and I
think that's because we use parmoline
oil to fry our chips and it's very high
in saturated fats unlike the U.S
vegetable oil what about the least
healthiest chip in each country over
here there are a lot of them that are
tied to 160 calories per 28 gram bag
show list but we did find that the 160
calorie chips with the highest fat
content are these no no the channel and
sour cream I love these guys
making them the least healthy if I did
have a bag that small it would contain
all of this
and here in India our highest calorific
chip is classic salted how lame how is
this the most calorific chip we sell
here lays if I had to run an extra mile
it wouldn't be for classic salted so you
know what the next most calorific chip
is
magic Masala baby blue lace we had to
end with this one super calorific I
don't know why I'm proud of that but uh
good great to know that this is and
forever will be the Maharaja of lays in
the interest of science I will taste
this liquid if I do this make sure to
subscribe to the food inside the channel
I didn't I never thought you could drink
a fart until today that was quite it was
like potato water
with a hint of salt